hey reject nation
I'm Greg Alba Sally Lomonaco it's here
hey Sally how are you we're just now
talking with each other just now
catching I bet you there's still
comments coming and go what
Sally's back yeah she is she's in my
life she's in other people's lives to
accept Jon's he stays in the room
although he's here you know before we
started filming
Sally's like you know Greg have you
heard of these visible Frank videos
she's like no I'm telling you these are
funny Greg so funny so funny so she so
we found this compilation she's probably
seen one or two of these other
compilations full disclosure when she's
faking her reaction aware of when she's
faking no we're gonna watch this now
courtesy of Sally
hey guys follow her on Instagram yes no
she's dead along with the riot right all
dead this better be funny or you're
gonna be in naughty time I'm gonna hit
play on the counter the rest most
Awkward interrupts that in a while
alright one two
[Music]
[Laughter]
why would you do this
[Music]
what are you this is so mean this is
abuse
scums child neglect kids that they're
dead want to be noticed by the funds
they love sorry again helping
psychoanalyze trauma these kids are
going through Oh
instead of film it's gonna start
touching themselves it was like oh yeah
I got ours you know the worst part is
they act excited that he's not
[Applause]
[Music]
see if they're too young that's what
it's not funny they think their debtors
of the baddest damn someone has a
YouTube channel
[Music]
look how pretty your hair is what did I
to
she should just go back to watching her
laptop yeah she's like that's what she's
do you think she should come back in
start hysterically crying and then
pretend to kill herself
[Music]
okay blog okay blog didn't really walk
out there you go somewhere else who
knows let me know something scary
[Music]
she looks so like abandoned
I never do this to a kid I could never
do throwing all our stuff this is like
the worst worst social experiment
[Music]
what don't stop doing the believe this
she can see her kids crying there's one
hilarious video you're watching a child
feel like she's been abandoned and
forgotten by her mom this for me sister
oh it's her sister makes a little more
[Music]
sense of your sisters she's not really
trying to be like I'm here that's all so
it's because she's giving up yeah she
feels like she's her sister
oh my god I worry for you in the future
Sally I swear to god this is not funny I
was talking about the other videos this
is so heartbreaking it's okay I'm a half
of each II have no [__] you hire people
to pretend to be cops
damn this was gone for a long time no
man
[Music]
five minutes ago oh man she's like no
you are not well Sally pick'em know
there was one mom like got so into it
and it was the funniest thing I've ever
seen in my life
oh that was not funny I think they got
more into it than whatever use that was
one of the most depressing things come
true really smiling the entire time I
just give the you know our AMA ties
ninety percent of these gift there's
like one or two kids who are like what's
happening to me the worst part is to
when they're invisible when they're
being sold on the fact that they're
invisible the parents are like oh my god
where's my kid or they're not freaking
out her whole family and moms like what
have you done like it's so into it okay
cuz one seems like a celebration that
they're invisible and the other seems
like a concern that
I remember in fifth grade fifth grade my
buddy and I were playing a joke all day
yeah Tommy and I we switched
personalities we searched bodies right
and then Tommy got in trouble but he was
going by Greg and so then he got kicked
out of the classroom and then someone
went yeah Greg's gone and then the whole
class started cheering even though the
joke was Tommy's pretending to be Greg
and the teachers even like to head the
teaching board stick whatever room was
like yeah this is just a joke they're
like Tommy but as a fifth grader I was
like that I'm not here oh man we just
watched a bunch of kids witness what it
feels like to be [__] abandoned all
for the sake of entertaining worried
about you being a mom Sally I think
you've been abandoned by her family and
they're all [__] flipping out enjoy
about it a sick video is disgusting
video I kind of hate whoever the last
person yeah that was like really messed
up that wasn't it's not like it's a it's
not like it's in front of their friends
and it's yeah she tried doing a
Redemption thing with going I don't know
good going bad you saw her because that
girl went from and this is funny -
something really - oh my god this isn't
a joke I've been him I'm forever lost
he's alternate reality
and she was like I didn't give dad like
you [__] did that for views and then
she hugged her she just stood there like
didn't even touch it oh my god that was
messed up oh I blame you
but hopefully people watch this reaction
we get some views right now I know I
could have pulled it off on you because
in the first one when she showed it in
the picture yeah whoa how are you doing
that Wow this would be funny if adults
thought they were disappearing and
started crying because then you could
just be like what an idiot
that is so kids well guys if you wanna
help this channel be invisible subscribe
because you won't get notified at here
words click that notification Bell check
us out on patreon I got to you show
reacts as a week and q and A's more
importantly follow this girl with an
incredibly dark sense of humor on her
social media as including the youtubes
links in the description box follow her
or else she'll never come back that's
why we stopped being friends for a hot
second everyone has their own rumors
they want to spread it's because she
stopped getting as many followers she
blamed me yeah so if you don't want her
to go invisible on this channel class a
comedy like that